erasing someone's experience and
reframing it and I in recent experience
but by by saying it isn't racist you are
erasing someone's experience no yes you
are inherently incorrect why that's not
the definition of racism what's the
definition of racism definition of
racism is believing that somebody is
inferior solely based on their race
that's prejudice racism is
institutionalized discrimination yes it
is yes it is yes it is time for the
latest installment have changed my mind
where we rationalize our positions on
controversial subjects for this
installment we decided to take on the
rapidly growing notion that Thanksgiving
is a racist holiday there's definitely a
racist history of Thanksgiving it's
genocide all holiday Thanksgiving lies
so we headed to UT Austin to see who
would be willing to step up sit down and
change my mind
first up meet Elizabeth what was your
name
Elizabeth Steven nice to meet you so
yeah let me set this up for enemy said
you haven't seen the show it's basically
set up it's not meant to be a debate
it's meant to be a conversation where we
rationalize our positions on
controversial topics grayness is a
controversial topic I'm sure that you've
heard there's been I mean there's been a
lot of noise about actually removing
Thanksgiving from being recognized as a
national holiday because people believe
that it's a racist holiday or steeped
rooted in racism colonialism I don't
agree I don't think it's a racist
holiday I think it's possibly the most
inclusive holiday that we have in the
United States I think it's a wonderful
holiday has done me good will do me good
god bless it happy Thanksgiving to you
before we go to you changing my mind
what are you most thankful for
everything get to go home and leave here
Mike we just started kind of a blast of
winter and then you get to come down
yeah exactly it's even though okay so
you are more than welcome to express to
me with we disagree with and change my
mind sure so I think there's a
difference between the origins of
Thanksgiving and the origins of the
country and the
giving that we celebrate now okay so I
what I was overhearing was calm hard to
hear but um is you believe there's
there's a lot of things to be thankful
for you know being able to live in this
country when many people are
unfortunately live in countries that
have terrorism and where women are not
allowed to have specific rights or where
specific groups are terrorized and so
obviously I am very thankful to live in
this country because we have so many
rights and we have so many freedoms but
I think that there's a difference
between recognizing the foundations of
how things even started and being able
to say I'm thankful that we live here
however our origins were in many ways
very based on European and white
supremacy and based on the ideas that we
came to - what was I guess the new world
and I was the modern United States and
we basically said and not necessarily on
the day of Thanksgiving this was not our
intentions but because the day of
Thanksgiving in many ways for a lot of
people was going to be saying well we
were able to break bread with the
Indians and we earned the Native
Americans and we were able to say listen
you taught that the last guy said
Indiana we're so sorry Native Americans
I should yeah cuz it's not that's
obviously a pretty controversial term
but whatever Wilson but some Native
Americans refer to themselves as Indians
so it's kind of yes we do so that's kind
of one of those things I'm just gonna
use the term Native American just
because I don't want to be sure yeah but
we were able to have this peaceful you
know dinner with them and basically say
listen we're here you guys are here
we'll be here together peacefully but
after that that's not really what
happened in the United States I mean
when you think about Mexican annexation
and when you think about the Native
Americans who lived here and were pushed
back in New Mexico when you think about
the the Alamo in San Antonio that's a
big thing is even at the Alamo they play
some kind of video that basically says
you know the use of what these noble
Texans and in reality the Mexicans at
the time who lived in Mexico and is now
this in the you know the bottom part of
the United States they let the Texans
live they let Americans coming live in
the United States the started in Mexico
sorry a little scrambling my words but
um they were the ones who were letting
people come and live here and they were
saying listen we're not going to be
peaceful we're actually here because you
we actually want you to come here
because we do not want the Imperial of
the imperial family in the more southern
parts of Mexico wanted to make sure that
other other countries didn't come and
take away the northern parts of Mexico
and that's why they asked people from
the colonies to come and live in in that
northern part of Mexico but what ended
up happening is they seceded from Mexico
and basically we immediately started
acting and with terror you know the
Texas Rangers who are incredibly racist
and killed and hung Mexicans
we have a lot of bait out we have you
know Christopher Columbus that's them
that's another pretty controversial like
Columbus Day is American indigenous
people say exactly so another renew said
Indian Native American it's indigenous
peoples day exactly its First Nations
you're never gonna get it right well
I'll try but I do understand yeah so
there's you know a lot of controversy
over Columbus and that's because when
Columbus came here you know first of all
he thought that this is where we get
this term Indians from because he
thought if they can get reached India
he'd obviously he'd parent wish not but
he had treated the people with this air
of European supremacy because he you
know immediately went and raped women he
you know killed people and it was all
this very big terror that obviously I
mean this is different from the pilgrims
who are you or you her dressed up as but
it basically shows that a lot of these
countries foundings is based on and even
if you if you separate the pilgrims from
you know Christopher Columbus it's still
based on this idea that we thought that
we were able to go and conquer a land
and say listen we know that you live
here and even if we're gonna give you
stuff is that we think that we have the
right to take over somebody else's land
and that we have the right and this is
what a lot of what we've done over the
years when it came to that you know that
the post-world War two and wakame
is that we decided that it was necessary
to go and save other countries from
potential from communism and so what
that led to was that and I know this is
kind of off topic but I kind of all
think of it I wanna let you speak I
don't want you to feel if I'm
interrupting yeah no not at all sure
this turkey hat is not covering the
camera do you want to wear the turkey
yeah yeah okay good no it does not it's
brand-new from Dollarama go ahead thank
you
so a lot of what we did with communism
is we are going to especially these
countries like Guatemala and we are
going in and we were giving them weapons
and we were giving them training on how
to fight radicals who were Pro communism
and at the time most people didn't know
a lot about communism and also gave them
STDs
you know I did not know that but I'm
glad that I can add that I'm just I'm
just tossing on to all of the white
American guilts because they disagree
with you glad I get to keep that into my
knowledge yeah I'm not a you know I'm
not a conspiracy theorist but that is
one thing I actually think Hillary
Clinton publicly apologized for that we
knowingly infected I believe it was I
believe was brought of molins with STDs
yeah and Guatemala
I've actually which is horrible wrong it
on to it and then I'll say something I'm
sure afterwards you'll be horribly
offended by but I want you to continue I
don't think you're would be happy if
you're yeah so I but I definitely think
I've been to Guatemala a few times and I
definitely think that what a lot of the
United States has done is we've taken
our roots of Pro you know European
supreme is not just promising well
supremacy white in terms of white
supremacy obviously where we are coming
from was primarily white or Spanish
which can be considered more on the
white side they're on the white side of
Europe so I just think that a lot of our
roots are based on white supremacy and
that modern-day Thanksgiving which is
the Thanksgiving that you seem to be
very adamant about is that yes we're
very very thankful for the people that
we have
that's actually not the case I was
making so can i okay I want to make sure
that I'm not interrupting you but no
what I was saying was specifically
Thanksgiving is a specific day you're
talking about 1621 you could say a week
was a week of feasting to check in 1621
and then it became a federally
recognized holiday by Abraham Lincoln in
I believe it was 1863 after the Civil
War and this is after the Emancipation
Proclamation and he said you know what
we need to holiday to unify Americans
black white South can fit you into the
Confederacy the Union let's look back to
this account that we have in history in
1621 where the early pilgrims would say
Wampanoag one put the name wrong yeah
those are the tribes that they came to
when they came to an abandoned village
it had been left by the French at that
point it was a day in 1621 where they
feasted with them so it's a specific
time that's recognized as a holiday for
Thanksgiving because it was precisely
about the old world and new world
bridging that divide and breaking bread
together and that was also symbolic of
what happened after the Emancipation
Proclamation the country was at war
that's why it's designed to be as
inclusive as possible any religion race
gender the whole point is Thanksgiving
is to give thanks for what it is that
you do have and it's important to
remember too that there were 50 years of
peace after that yeah 1621 so for a very
long time
so what I am saying is that Thanksgiving
a lot will say well it depends on what
you think Thanksgiving no it doesn't
depend there's historical documentation
this is why we celebrate Thanksgiving it
was this feast 50 years of peace
afterward that's a wonderful thing it's
not racist at all now if people then
want to talk about then you went through
a whole list I mean you went all the way
down to Texas Rangers yeah at first of
all you were saying Walker Texas Rangers
like Chuck Norris has nothing to do with
the early pilgrims but you were going
all the way through that and this is
what I see a lot of people doing you did
it to a more extreme example you know
going down the ELMO but people say well
because afterward there were born acts
committed therefore that taints
Thanksgiving and what I am saying is no
a Thanksgiving is not exclusive in any
way it's actually designed to be
inclusive by it's inclusive by design
and that sets the precedent which you
would have to apply to every single
holiday from Christmas to Passover to
to Ramadan any holiday because you could
say well after Christmas there's they
crucified Jesus or there's a Spanish
Inquisition you could go to the
atrocities that obviously you know Jews
are not blameless either and of course
they've been the victim this happens
throughout society where people are
sometimes sometimes there's a nail
sometimes they're the hammer for some
reason though there is a
disproportionate focus on kind of what
you brought up white European settlers
who came here as though they are
singularly unique or responsible for
these acts of evil and it comes up
around the time of Thanksgiving and I
don't think it could be less appropriate
or less productive I think it's divisive
and I think it actually fractures us as
opposed to celebrate taking part in
celebration that should encourage unity
so the only thing that and I see I mean
obviously I see what you're saying yeah
but if these 50 pieces that are the 50
years of peace and unity that you feel
good yes
and then you also spoke about the
Emancipation Proclamation how that was
getting rid of slavery however just
because I got rid of slavery didn't mean
that african-americans in this country
were you know they still went through so
much I'm not saying at all if anyone is
blameless but it's see but it's the idea
that you're saying that what I wanted
clear the owners I thought that I was
cuz that's when it was federally
recognized the whole yes so but what I'm
trying to say is that Thanksgiving I
guess in your kind of sense no no I want
to be very clear do you do we both agree
that that is why we celebrate
Thanksgiving yes no rooms and and
aboriginals or indigenous it's not
generally there's a very specific reason
where we picked that day yeah and it's
1621 and then it goes to 1863 with
Abraham Lincoln declaring it an official
holiday it's just because a lot to be
linked there's wiggle room there's no
wiggle room as to why we celebrate
Thanksgiving yeah now if you want to say
we shouldn't celebrate it because of and
go down the list of grievances afterward
you can do that and I'm more than
willing to talk with you about that but
I don't think that that's fair to tar
and feather a celebration because we
choose what we celebrate well I don't
think that we shouldn't celebrate
Thanksgiving and that's um and like I
was saying before it's cuz I think there
are so many things that we have to be
thankful for but I think that there's a
separation now sure between the original
reason for celebrating it and why we
celebrate it now more
people I think when you think of
celebrating Thanksgiving now is more
like oh I'm thankful for my mom I'm
thankful for my dad you know I'm
thankful I have a sort of Family Matters
exactly and so a full house or something
like that you know and that's why I'm
having this conversation because I'm
amazed at how many students here have no
ideas the actual history of Thanksgiving
yeah I think it is important for them to
know because I also think it's if they
understand it's far harder to lead them
astray with lives of mass genocide yeah
well I mean mass genocide is a complete
topic that are the unique sing really
unique evils of colonialism we can go on
down that trail afterwards I mean I'm
sure with Thanksgiving I can be that way
- let's start with Thanksgiving it seems
like we agree on that Thanksgiving is a
good thing well it's so it I think that
there are - but there are still two
different topics that I think it's okay
to go and say I'm thankful for this but
I think that we still have to recognize
what this country has been built on the
backs of who this has been built on you
know and the actual entire history
rather than just thinking about this one
day that crazy but my point is this is
one day you celebrate that one day you
can go into any history classroom right
now we just had several student it this
almost always taught every student have
asked so far said I've been taught
basically about the genocide and the
evils of the settlers none of them were
aware of the evil and barbarism that the
natives committed against each other
well doc I mean I have been taught about
that actually I mean yeah okay that's
also it's an intellectual fallacy to say
though well because this happened
afterwards and applied to Thanksgiving
so I want to make sure that we both
agree Thanksgiving great day to
celebrate good and then separate from
that we can get into what you disagree
with on the founding of the country but
that doesn't apply to the celebration of
Thanksgiving but would you not say that
the if we're thinking about the
foundations of this country and then
thinking about see I feel like you're
trying to separate the two days but then
yesterday and the actual foundation of
the country and they shouldn't be
separated because we have to think about
the fact that they there was a time
before Thanksgiving when you know when
we first first of all wouldn't we
started yes we were the I'm not a direct
associate with the pilgrim so I can't
say we necessarily but are you doing on
23andme yes I have actually no pilgrim
in your background I'm not that I'm
bullish you know yes French good for you
there aren't many left obviously Polish
Jews it was yes it was an unfortunate
time for us that's doable
but yeah but I would definitely think
that and this is just my opinion
obviously because we're just swapping
opinion true but um I think that there
has to be an association between the two
just because if you don't think about
everything that has happened in the past
what it can why can't you be why can't I
be thankful that we're no longer
committing these massive lemons you're
Jewish I am Jewish yeah so do you
celebrate Passover yes okay how do you
celebrate Passover it's not necessary
see the thing is with Jewish holidays a
lot of them are not necessarily
celebrations they're reminders of the
past okay sure
and so I'd uh so I think the
Thanksgiving in some ways should be
Passover would remind you of what in the
past I think that all the atrocities
that Jews have gone through in the past
I mean every you know especially like
Yom Kippur is one where we think about
how we didn't have we didn't have time
to get out of these excuses and I lists
I do not want to sound like an
anti-semite but I think we'll agree here
would none of us would say that
historically Jews are blameless in
certain conflicts right well I mean I
that I can't get into I would just I'm
not at your holidays at your holidays
do you also have a day of mourning over
the atrocities that Jews have committed
um
I personally know but I also don't think
that I'm educated enough on those topics
in order to have like a actual
conversation about that sure but I'm not
when my point is it's applying the same
standard right to Jewish holidays yeah
and I think by the way I support
Israel's right to exist I certainly
support them in the face of Hamas and
Hezbollah and look at a six-day war I'm
far more concerned that's what people
think I'm Jewish and call me I'm working
for Jewish Hills but I certainly
wouldn't say that any group of people
are blameless but the point is you're
saying we need to celebrate this
American holiday and recognize the fatal
flaws in the United States doesn't sound
to me like you're applying that same
standard to Jewish holidays well today I
I
that that's definitely something that is
flat and I also don't know I wouldn't
say I know enough about how to change
the Jewish system I would if I could I
would definitely try and implement
something like that but I think there's
also something to be said about then
let's hear your suggestions on how we
employing it to the American system I
just want to point out we choose
holidays to celebrate and people
shouldn't have a gun to their head to
say you can only celebrate Passover if
you also go over the LaVon affair or
whatever but I don't think that there
should be definite in regards to how
people celebrate holidays I mean there
are people who don't celebrate birthdays
and things like that and usually you're
not blameless on your person to say like
oh well you committed a mass murder so I
guess you can turn 32 this year really I
was a prick
oh well that's unfortunate I turned 19
with I was not a prick okay good for you
here you're one step ahead of it I said
because you mentioned we should also
include this sort of day of mourning the
state recognizing the atrocities I think
this is being singularly applied to
Thanksgiving I think it's being seen you
really applied because of what you
presented as white European supremacy
which I disagree with but let me show I
want you to finish that thought and then
we'll kind of move on okay so um
basically I just think that I think it
could be applied to a lot of more
holidays obviously maybe not some of
them like Valentine's Day and things
like that but I don't really know the
origins of some of these holidays i
Esther's at Hallmark might have to pay
yeah exactly but I don't know and I
don't know enough about like the origins
of Christianity I don't really know that
much about the Crusades and things like
that so I really can't make too many
arguments when it comes to other
religions and other holidays that we
celebrate which are often religious
based however you're suggesting on
Thanksgiving is you can celebrate
Thanksgiving but no so I actually think
that what we should do is we should just
constantly be mindful of what we have
done in the past and so that we don't
repeat these actions in the future and
in that during that time so let me ask
us because you just mentioned you just
went down a whole laundry list right bad
things that what Europeans did sorry
yeah do you also think that we should be
very conscious of the incomparable
barbaric acts of evil to the Native
Americans committed against each other
on that day
um well the employee Mexicans you
mentioned the Aztecs si oh yeah the
Aztecs and the Incas however those were
Peruvian Incans were / yeah that aspects
of the Mayans but should they not be
able to celebrate any national holiday
without recognizing the horrible evil
far worse than anything colonialists did
that they did to each other like ripping
someone's heart off cannibalizing them
in front of their wives and kids should
they not be able to celebrate Cinco
DeMayo
well first of all thinking am i I don't
think enough people really know the
origins behind Cinco DeMayo yeah sort of
national yes any holidays in Africa even
though they were the ones who started
this what we know is the modern slave
trade and it still goes on there yeah so
I definitely think that obviously you
can argue that everybody has hats a
little um every that everybody is flawed
in some way however I think that in
order to really make some kind of
progress in the future you have to
really it's kind of like I like seeing
they and they talk about their sins lot
and they go to the priest and they're
like this is what I've done and so I
think that there's something Noble and
actually very progressive and being able
to say this is what we've done in the
past and now I'm thankful that we're
here and that we don't that we're not
currently living in that situation and
so in the future we now know that this
can't happen again
yeah I'm gonna turn it up a little bit
on you here so I hope you appreciate
this not the way that's controversial
but I don't think that you could argue
anyone has done that more than Western
European Americans no one has been bro
beaten and admitted to guilt more for
example in other countries right you if
you were to conquer people or commit
mass genocide you subjugate them you
don't give them back land that's not
what happens which we done with Native
Americans when you talk about the acts
of barbarism you know there was no mass
genocide that's just not accurate they
were committing murder and massive
numbers if we talk about giving the land
back to Native Americans which I don't
know if you've suggested or you
necessarily support that or was somebody
else you know give it back to the
Mohawks
it's very technical no but my point is
there are no debt national days of
mourning where the Mohawks and Mohicans
are recognizing the mass atrocities they
committed scalping we learned from them
they're not seeing that from the Mayans
this is why this land was conquered and
it wasn't mass genocide by the way
50% of the natives have wiped out the
estimates are about 30% of settlers so
that's not really a mess to decide how
many Gestapo were taking up my Jews at
Auschwitz zero that's what genocide
looks like right this was a war with one
side that had horses I'm sure you know
they hadn't domesticated horses they
didn't even use a wheel yes so this was
a very regressive Society who lived here
by the way for thousands of years we
both agreed that thousands of years
let's go 1621 200 years we end slavery
so we don't even need to end
cannibalization or burning people alive
or ripping out their hearts but we ended
slavery yeah I think that's a good thing
and I think trying to make it seem as
though white Western Europeans as always
based on some form of racial supremacy
are uniquely responsible for these acts
of evil and that is what you proposed
and I haven't heard anyone propose that
there should be days of mourning for
Native Americans to atone for the crap
that they've pulled or days of mourning
for the Jews to atone for what they
pulled our days of mourning for the
Palestinians to atone for what they
pulled it always seems to be white
European settlers when the fact is in
the United States of America we did
commit acts of evil that's human nature
but we are singularly unique for ending
so many acts of evil in record time
however you could argue that white
Americans white Europeans are in a
position of power compared to so many
people consider especially Native
Americans especially you know other
African Americans you know me my any
other Asian power now because we won the
war well so but to continue with my
point I think that a lot of policy is
but do you not agree with you do not see
what I just would you not agree that
there's that that's a subtext here that
is important I definitely time I say
well what about Nate you go I don't know
if about that what about the famines you
go I don't know if about that but you
seem to have a laundry list of all your
grievances with white European settlers
yeah and you also don't seem to know a
lot about the acts of the acts of evil
that were committed against them well I
understand both we understand that they
go both ways right did you say against
uh against against Europeans and
certainly against natives from natives
yes it was more brutal than Native
Americans I would my only argument to
that would just be that you're talking
about you know natives committing
atrocities against Native
and that's in there oh but this was when
they were in their own land
this was their land this was their
civilization it wasn't their land when
they were going in hard and okay so what
so what separates it is up is a pond
well the fact is they were going into
someone else's territory killing raping
their women burning them alive because I
wanted to take their stuff yeah we
didn't go and kill them and burn them
alive we went in and we traded for
example the island of Manhattan and then
they said sometimes there were
atrocities committed but a lot of the
time we bought land and then they said
well no hon a second we don't have the
same concept of personal property
Manhattan Manhattan we purchase for 60
guilders worth now it's been taught in
this school I believe that 60 guilders
accounts to $25 worth of junk I've read
this and it's academic I think it was UT
could have been the University of
Massachusetts um like that don't
fact-check me on this book was written
60 guilders acquit equates to $25 worth
of modern junk 60 guilders was actually
nearly 10,000 animal pelts and lumber
and nut woods that I was given for the
island of Manhattan that the Lynott Bay
in Canarsie did not want they live in
what his modern Brooklyn was purchased
we settled there peacefully then they
come back in and say hey we want it back
all I thought this was at least because
I don't on the same concept of personal
property
then a war starts and of course the
settlers win that is very different I
would say that it's far more permissible
than the Mohicans going in and just
slaughtering all the Mohawks they can
find I think I'm scalping them the only
thing is that when you think about it so
the sutlers who came and had obviously
been educate in a different point in a
different way they had different values
they had different upbringing is I mean
as he said before we they the Native
American suits live there before they
didn't have access they hadn't
domesticated many animals or horses and
they hadn't what they did not have you
know thousands of years that's a good
question but I think a lot of it is
based on their religion and a lot of
that they respect they respect nature
they respect respect nature I immunity
hunted and fished more species to
extinction per capita than any people in
the history of the world I don't care at
all I didn't really mean it by that in
that sense I think there was more of a
respect towards like the
physical nature sorry I'm just gonna
heat it cuz I learned this stuff in
school no wait they fished them out of
existence they didn't have the wheel
wait they never used horses everything I
learned was a lie yeah and I had to
learn about what really happened with
these these turf wars with a lot of a
pilgrims and early settlers and so I
think that that is really I mean you
would be able to argue that those were
just like underdeveloped civilization
why this well when we say they didn't
use the wheel I just cuz I develop it I
think that development is kind of
however you think development should be
I mean some people believe that
spiritual development is more important
than actual like material development
and being able to sure some people think
that it's incredibly important to you
have access to electricity but other
people think that it you know having if
that's really like a basis of what
people's values are based on what they
believe is material
rights equal rights yeah rights for
women we both agree good things I mean
not enslaving and raping women in kids I
mean are some cultures better than other
cultures I would not argue that some
cultures are better than other cultures
I would arguing different that cultures
are different okay well then we just
disagree I think that the culture that
says you can't rape and scalp women is
better than the culture that says you
can steal women I would like to say I
would like to say that in that type of
in that standpoint that that's a
difference I was thinking more on the
idea of like cultural value is based on
those are cultural value I'll about the
vision for the conflict right yeah
reason for the conflict is when early
settlers come in they go you don't get
to enslave their children and burn these
people alive yeah and by the way let's
what you mentioned the Mexicans I mean
you go down the Jeana how many
conquistadors there were no I don't and
this is not a trick question yeah I
didn't know I don't know because I
wasn't taught in college so I don't know
how I was taught in college the
conquistadors came in and they they
conquered these people and they were
brutal and they were barbaric and they
wiped him out is that what you were
taught um yeah okay I understand that's
what I was talking there about 500 yeah
do you know how many natives there were
many many tens of thousands do you know
how many tons of gold band that I don't
know do you know how they procured said
gold by enslaving because they had no
regard for human rights whatsoever and
so they enslaved people usually
after raping and beating them and
stealing their women if they were
fertile enough and they would say okay
you have to go and get us gold and your
options are get us gold or die
so Cortez came with 500 conquistadors do
you think you can take over an entire
land because he went through Mexico you
went through all that any atrocities
you can take over in conquered entire
land with 500 conquistadors what's
required as natives who were so upset
because of the barbarism and how
mistreated they were they felt that they
were and they knew they were better
treated by European settlers who came
and they said we're gonna take our
chances with the guys who have the
boon-'boon
yeah I actually that's I talked about
that briefly earlier I might not have
talked about it and extent that was kind
of realistic that's why I just kind of
went down my list that's true and so
that is that is 100% true and there were
the only thing is that I adore culture
is better I say it's superior well I
mean I'll agree to disagree about that
but I mean I see I see what your point
is the only thing that I have to say
about that is that they were ripping out
hearts I love children how can you
disagree that that's an inferior culture
I don't I I'm sorry like I and I respect
you sitting now but because he spoke but
ripping out hearts I don't believe in
sacrificing him but that was a central
value to the culture how can we not say
the culture that says no no no no no we
don't rip out hearts to the sun-god
and we're going to subjugate you so that
you don't continue to rip out hearts to
the sun-god how can you say that one
culture is not better than the other
Jubilee I mean I just never really
believed that it was specifically our
right to go in and see that type of
thing it's just not I mean I'm just not
prone right to rip out the heart to be
honest if you love the society I guess
the people were boring didn't get born
like oh I'm signed enough to have my
heart flown down like a pocket lift oh I
think you're saying oh it's unbelievable
and it's a Jewish person especially when
you really understand the importance of
Jews and I believe is Jews need to
Homeline with Israel because I had their
rights completely violated for a long
time I mean what do you think would
happen if if right now today the
Palestinian ripped the heart out of a
Jewish child is sacrificed - mom - uh -
a lot well I don't think that I would
necessarily happen of course it wouldn't
happen but I'm also saying that this is
I mean we're talking about a time that
was thousands well not thousands of
years ago but it where it originated
by the way thousands of years ago with
the settlers to is my point
yeah my point is they had thousands of
years still ripping out hearts and
cannibalizing Western Europeans had
thousands of years plumbing and the
wheel and horses yeah one is better in
my opinion yeah you don't think one is
better I it's just that I don't think
that we have the right to go another to
other civilizations is basically just
trying it sure it might make it I mean I
think there's something Noble and saying
sure that we could try and make your
life easier but I don't think that we
have the right to say just tell other
people what they're doing wrong and this
is what they believe in this is their
it's a religion and I think that
bringing Judaism into it is actually is
not is not in my opinion a very good
thing just because I want that well I
think that Christianity into a - I'm
saying I believe that the Jewish culture
is better than the ripping out arts
culture I mean I would also say that how
I just I don't really like bringing the
Holocaust into things like that just
bring the cost into I mean it's been
brought in just before but I definitely
think that talking about modern-day
Judaism and then referring to older
religions and Mayans which to this day
still practice but do not continue with
these are dripping out rituals and maybe
that's because because it's
impermissible well maybe that's because
we came in and we said maybe you
shouldn't do that anymore but at the
same time we shouldn't be saying instead
you should convert to Christianity
instead you should convert to our
religion because it's superior I think
that well namely it was because at that
point the reason we had to do it was
because to ensure that people weren't
being cannibalized and having their
hearts ripped out the only sort of
failsafe was you're gonna put a cross
next to your initial there so we know
that you know you've moved on from heart
removal territory yeah the only thing
that I think is that is that that just
starts the process of a simple
assimilation that still is very
prominent you do you like assimilation
yeah I think as a matter of fact that's
the biggest argument against Native
American aside against Native Americans
because most of them assimilated and
most unassimilated because most wanted
to I I would actually think that a lot
of them and I mean obviously I didn't
live during that time so I really can't
make
I'm older than you but I wasn't quite
alive at that doing some Grey's here in
the sideburns and makes me sad but I
definitely would think that fear was the
reason that a lot of people assimilated
that's the reason a lot of people
assimilate today fears having their
hearts ripped out or being cannibal I
but other natives they said whatever is
going on with these new guys who have
the funny translucent skin it's got to
be better than being cannibalized and
burned alive I'm gonna go with you
we gave them some firewater and let them
Duke it out and then came in and picked
up the pieces and I just think it's
important to understand the history of
this I agree that there were for example
there were some trades that went on that
were terrible and there were some acts
of evil that were absolutely committed
from European colonialists I want to
make it very clear that I'm not denying
that okay
but in this conversation you have
presented it as though they are
singularly unique while equating all
cultures I'm holding one culture
accountable and what I am saying and the
reason that I support Thanksgiving not
only as a day but as a concept and I'm
grateful for the settlers is that
Western European culture in the
Constitution and American culture
culture of ideas not of people not an F
no state like we have the Native
Americans I believe is a wonderful thing
I'm very glad that that happened I'm
glad that the colonialists came here and
that they created the kind of country
that we all get to live in now I'm okay
with it and I think they are singularly
unique and responsible for ending acts
of barbarism and evil across the world
that the Native Americans continued and
were continued in continents to the
globe many places to this day so I don't
think you can hold them accountable as
being the only people who need to mourn
their acts of evil I think instead they
should be praised and held accountable
for the fact that they are singularly
unique and stopping a lot of that but
don't you think they should also be held
accountable for
I think no one's been held more
accountable than they have I mean I
think that there have been if you I mean
I've been to like Germany and they have
entire museums thousands like it just
seems like thousand monuments museums
coffee back home I think Germany sucks
it up with Jeremy a place that bans
books because I don't want you to know
about their their distorted history I
don't think we did it up until only like
in the last several decades and you
can't speak freely there's no freedom of
speech in Germany by the way it's a hate
crime if you talk about the Holocaust
and unsavory terms or Nazi Germany which
I am not at all I'm saying not at all
pro Holocaust pro-pro Alliance of good
pro-israel okay I'm probably more
pro-israel than anyone you know right
here but I do think that if someone is
going to be a Holocaust denier that
shouldn't be a crime and it is in
Germany I don't think that a country
that has no freedom of speech and that
bans books and by the way in the realm
of history that's pretty new German went
to war with the entire world twice yeah
yeah I mean that axis yes yes a bad
guess of cultural relativism we see them
as the axis of evil do they see us as
the axis of evil differences we weren't
the ones guessing Jews so I say that
objectively they were the axis of evil
no yes I'm not disagree so now we can
objectively say that gassing Jews a
Holocaust is objectively evil but we
can't say it's objectively evil to rip
out the heart of an unwilling native to
sacrifice it on a parent I mean that's
fine but I definitely think that the I
just don't think that it's our right to
go in and take away what we've done unto
this day is we have basically put Native
Americans to design we've put other
ethnicities to the side and we basically
said if you want to live in our society
you have to assimilate yourself and you
have to learn how to become a true
America
I mean that's I have literally no idea
what it means to be a true American
because our country is literally based
off of immigrants and so the fact that
today we don't even live in a world
where where we live in a world where
people believe that English should be
the national language and which entire
populations are you know told that they
aren't American enough because they
speak Spanish or because they don't you
know talker look or dress like they're
American and there's no real definition
I'll tell you what a true American is a
true American as someone who this is the
beauty of being American and I think you
conflated two things you said we cast
aside Native Americans we didn't most of
them assimilated most them willingly
some of them unwillingly we didn't cast
aside minorities we freed them and then
we said let's have a national day of
Thanksgiving and let's celebrate this in
unity we didn't cast women aside we gave
them equal rights and then said okay
let's off we made progress progress
happens in stages I know as opposed to
the thousands of years of Native
Americans good luck on them getting the
women right to vote so I don't think you
said we cast aside natives we can't
decide all these people none of that is
accurate little things are accurate
because and then you say we're a nation
of immigrants well hold on second I
thought we just cast immigrants aside
neither one of those things are true now
the one of those things are true the
truth is that unlike Native Americans
who wanted an ethnos state and by the
way an extreme example because they
wanted only their tribal bloodlines to
continue and you see this in other
countries across Africa you see it
across the Middle East being a true
American is subscribing to a set of
ideals and those can be found in the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution and the amendments they're
in that's the wonder of the United
States and that's why so many Native
Americans so many Haitians who migrated
here Italians Jews Polish Jews at one
point of course Irish have all become
American because it's about subscribing
to these ideals that people will
traverse the entire ocean they will they
will brave the stormiest seas to try and
willingly assimilate to American culture
and don't leave it on this I believe
that's because it is superior and we
ended evil to a degree that has not been
seen before the United States doesn't
mean that we're perfect and that's why I
love Thanksgiving and I'm grateful that
we both live here and I'm grateful that
you wore the Hat
[Music]
sorry there's a little bit of water
there so don't you glad to get what was
your name
Safa nice to meet you Steven nice to
meet you so yeah I'm sure you know the
topic of discussion today I know that
we're often taught especially in schools
and Columbus Day Thanksgiving it's a
racist holiday I don't agree I think
it's a wonderful holiday that should
unify the nation I think it has done me
good will do me good I say God bless it
happy Thanksgiving and if you disagree
you're more than welcome to change my
mind if you want to scooch in you can't
see enough to lean yeah so I think she
means actually my favorite holiday as
well well I think that where people
where it gets controversial is the
origin story that we're taught about it
sure that Native Americans and pilgrims
peacefully got together and shared a
meal and that's the story that kids are
taught that's kind of the narrative that
we push especially now that you're
dressed as a pilgrim I appreciate that
you recognize a garden this wasn't all
for naught but I saw a video that was
made in 2015 and it's from cut.com
and it's a video that is a series of
interviews that the interview Native
Americans and they asked them to
describe Thanksgiving in one word right
and these people say Massacre racist
false holiday true unpeaceful these
kinds of things so I think if we're
asking Native Americans how they feel
about the holiday and that's what
they're saying then shouldn't we listen
to them oh sure you can listen to them
it doesn't mean if that's what the
holiday is okay so so before we get that
why is it your favorite holiday um I
really like cooking oh and I that's what
the holidays about for me it's about
giving thanks to the people in my life I
just think that when people talk about
how things look what are you most
thankful for um I guess being able to go
home to my family and having that mean
yeah right but I think that when people
are talking about how Thanksgiving is
controversial that's what they're
talking about so how do you how do you
come back to
well it's incorrect it's incorrect it's
incorrect so Thanksgiving is a
celebration of in the 1620s when the the
pilgrim settlers did have a meal of
Thanksgiving with the I think it's
pronounced well I want to want the no AG
is that you know I'm actually I right
welcome to like in celebrating then had
had fifty years of peace after that now
if we want to talk about the fact that
there have been some acts of barbarism
committed setbacks yeah of course
committed against Native Americans and
of course committed against Native
Americans from Native Americans
themselves obviously yeah that happened
obviously throughout the historical
timeline but that didn't happen at
Thanksgiving and it's interesting
because you know you know when
Thanksgiving was recognized officially
as a federal holiday so this is what I
actually think it's the least racist
holiday out there because it's
proactively a holiday designed to
symbolize unity was Abraham Lincoln who
wanted to after the Civil War after some
to minified I was real quick cuz I don't
have that kind of poll as soon as a
hunch back up their face mask so after
the Emancipation Proclamation actually
very soon after Abraham Lincoln's
thought it would be a good idea to have
a national holiday that symbolized unity
for all Americans at this point black
Americans white Americans and so they
did look back to that 1921 original
Thanksgiving that symbolized the old
world converging with the new world in
50 years of peace so I'm looking to
create a unifying holiday across all
racial divides he looked to a moment in
early American history before we were
officially a country where that happened
as well so that's why we celebrate
Thanksgiving but even if it's if
something proactively promotes unity if
there are people who don't feel that way
true and those people were marginalized
and affected by the acts of barbarism
that that you just that you said
happened nothing Thanksgiving did it
happen throughout history sure no that's
but if Thanksgiving is about a moment of
unity between Pilgrims and Native
Americans
no but the rest of the time that those
two peoples interacted was filled with
violence and inequality yeah then why is
it just that day well a couple of things
first if it wasn't the rest of the time
it was most of the time millions of
Native American people died because of
colonial people coming over people it's
estimated actually about 50% of Native
Americans the sailors were wiped out
they came here 30% so in other words
it's not a genocide as well it's
actually not a genocide my definition
well on second guys let's just keep the
conversations between two folks they did
bring disease here they did bring
disease with them and it did wipe out
quite a few Native Americans that was
actually before the Thanksgiving that's
why they came back to an abandoned
village I'm sure you're aware of that
because they were wiped out by diseases
well I hadn't encountered because they
hadn't domesticated most animals yet you
know they had domesticated horses they
had no contact with horses they were
technologically very regressive they
didn't use the wheel so what happened
was there was a moment of peace that for
50 years we had a large a very long
portion of history that was very
peaceful with Native Americans there are
multiple alliances between new settlers
and Native Americans because Native
Americans were warring with each other
and we do choose though as a holiday to
celebrate this moment of unity we choose
to celebrate a positive moment I mean
you can look at Veterans Day or Memorial
Day well they're horrible out those
holidays what you do same thing was
fourth of July yes soon it was Christmas
what Ramadan I'm Muslim what okay
because obviously slavery still
practiced across the Islamic world so
you believe that okay
no is it not I mean it's practiced
across the entire world not just the
United States versus the Islamic world
is it it's the world the Islamic world
all different kinds of parts we in
comparison to example the settlers in
modern America the point is we're not
celebrating that with Ramadan are we're
not celebrating the Spanish Inquisition
when we celebrate Christmas right
Christians committed some horrible
actions and we're not celebrating war
with Native Americans when we celebrate
Thanksgiving we're celebrating a moment
of peace and unity because it shows that
it can be done I think what people want
is
an acknowledgement that these things
happened I've already done that right
yeah which an acknowledgment of these
racist things that did happen and
implying that maybe the narrative that
we push isn't true and that
acknowledging that there was a
disagreement and violence between these
people sure I think people just want
that acknowledgement and by out flat out
saying Thanksgiving is not racist
I think a better way to say I think you
could say these things did happen and
this is what it's based on and
Thanksgiving has evolved and dipping on
something else but that doesn't mean I'm
going to erase the opinions of Native
Americans who suffered well who raised
opinions of Native Americans who suffer
that's not what I'm doing by saying
Thanksgiving isn't inherently racist you
are erasing that so in other words
unless I say that Thanksgiving is
inherently racist I am erasing the
opinion of all Native Americans yeah I
mean not all but those who feel that
Thanksgiving is racist marginalized
group you know and we're pushing this
narrative that they were happy to have
Thanksgiving they were and for 50 years
they were ok it wasn't that a good thing
I've heard that that dinner didn't
happen what did happen not only to and
I've also heard as you know people try
to go to the Winthrop diaries later and
I believe it was in the 1630s where they
had Thanksgivings during times of war
against the Pequod's but that wasn't all
the same thing that was they were
thankful for during battle that they had
fewer casualties and so I think that's
probably what you're conflating they
teach that often in school I know it's
kind of interesting that you say we
don't teach any of this when I went to
college when I went to high school I was
only taught about colonialism and how
awful the settlers were I never taught I
was never taught for example of all the
warring between the tribes of the
cannibalism of the scalping that they
were doing I was taught that they were
peaceful people and these settlers came
in and sold their land when the reality
was they were warring they were barbaric
we had many years of peace we came in we
purchased land we traded we had a
healthy trading relationship for a while
they lived here this was their land they
were truly good argue that the
colonialists were barbarians for coming
in and taking their land I certainly
went to the colonialist were barbaric
compared to us today and I would
certainly say the Native Americans
we're barbaric and their practices
compared to the colonialist just because
you don't agree on understand what
something doesn't make it barbaric well
I just mean you know the fact that in
their plumbing I use the wheel they
didn't have plumbing there's no plumbing
the Romans that doesn't make them suit
inferior just needs a barbaric okay I'm
totally barbaric I'm talking about less
evolved technologically and societal so
definition rather than the connotation
yes definition rather than ecology so
you seem to be someone who ignores
connotations no I don't because
Thanksgiving has a negative connotation
in some people's eyes but you're
ignoring that connotation so does
Christmas yeah so does Christmas you
know I don't talk about that either
I do talk about Christmas I love
Christmas I think it's wonderful and
should be celebrated I know that you've
made it clear that you disagree you
don't like Christmas
you don't like Ramadan you don't like
Easter you don't like Thanksgiving I
believe that there are certain moments
throughout American history I let fourth
of July Independence that can be
celebrated regardless of imperfections
throughout history and I think that's
important to note and I think that it's
a good thing to honor and show that
there can be a moment in time of peace
because we had it for 50 years
regardless of the wars that happened
before we came here
so jury's out wait 50 years do you think
Native Americans are thankful for being
put on reservations like centuries after
being given reservations after they lost
wars yeah okay yeah let me let me ask
you this let me ask you this so you
don't like any of the holidays okay
and you say that I'm completely ignoring
someone's opinion if I don't agree with
something yeah that's out I said I said
that you're ignoring the opinion of
marginalized people who the holiday
effects who the glorification of the
holiday negatively affects because any
erases what they say happened to them
and they were here first
so they should have a say in what
[Music]
the narrative is about yeah I know one
thing they can't have a say I don't
believe it's a racist holiday I mean I
racing someone's experience is a form of
racism it racing someone's experience
and reframing it and erasing experience
but by by saying it isn't racist you are
erasing someone's experience no yes you
are inherently incorrect why that's not
the definition of racism what's the
definition of racism definition of
racism is believing that somebody is
inferior solely based on their race
that's prejudice racism is
institutionalized discrimination yes it
is yes it is yes it is well I'm not an
institution so right now we're going
with the individualized definition of
racism individually of being racist let
me ask you this maybe we can find some
common ground here because you said you
loved Thanksgiving but you don't like
the holidays what should we do then
right contact is made between two
civilizations for example this happens
right one has rifles and one has wheels
and horses and engage in peace and then
there are land disputes when land was
purchased so let's just get rid of what
we have right now what would you do you
would have no Thanksgiving what will we
do what what should the United States be
I'm genuinely curious I think just an
acknowledgement like everyone should
acknowledge what happened yes I believe
everyone does I don't think I have okay
so is it okay to acknowledge that there
were acts of horrible evil and violence
across all sides and still celebrate
Thanksgiving for what it is is that okay
it's a good question I thought that part
do you think that it is better to
celebrate Thanksgiving and recognize a
moment of unity and encourage it both
with the early settlers of the early
pilgrims in the Native Americans as well
as after the Civil War do you think it's
more productive to have a day to
celebrate that and encourage that kind
of unity and bridging that cultural
divide or do you think it's less
productive I think it's performative so
if someone hurts you signaling yeah so
something's performative then does it
really do the good that you're
describing what good am i describing the
unity
the unity that you're describing like if
something is performative and is that
unity really there or is it a
performative unity which doesn't
actually well I think I mean you just
talked about Thanksgiving cooking and
spending time with family I mean that's
that's unity right there right that's
prioritizing giving thanks I mean I
think that Thanksgiving honestly is the
least exclusive holiday Christian you
know Christmas Christianity would
exclude people in Ramadan would exclude
people of other religions you know you
can take your pick from any of the
religious holidays Thanksgiving is be
thankful for what it is that you do have
whether you're a Christian whether
you're family gonna talk about what
happened Americans I mean we've talked
about it all throughout my life and I
learned about it I still talk about you
gonna acknowledge it at the dinner table
I don't know have to you should okay
right no why not I didn't say I wouldn't
he should okay well thank you for
telling me what I should and should not
do in my personal time you're welcome
and you wouldn't think that that is a
bad at all in any way as overstepping
bounds or being pushy well maybe you
should discuss with your family of the
the history the deal and that wasn't
accurate that you brought here to the
table and maybe you can all get an
accurate account of what happened
historically and maybe discuss as well
the acts of barbarism is still go on
since you're Muslim across the Islamic
world do you do that at Ramadan yeah I
do actually
you do okay so what do you discuss at
Ramadan I discuss indentured servitude I
like to discuss how I think that Islam
itself isn't in certain Middle Eastern
countries how it's in eating pool for
women sure and as a woman and as a
Muslim woman who was raised Muslim I
believe that that's an equal and I will
acknowledge that I like to acknowledge
how there Saudi Arabia for example is
guilty of hypocrisy you know the royal
family has so much money I know you're
talking a lot lower right now yeah
because you're concerned about
criticizing Islam yeah I guess so maybe
that's just ingrained in me
what let's picture we're yeah it is guys
talking to well I appreciate it and I
appreciate your your intellectual
honesty there and that you have those
discussions I don't by the way I don't
think you need to do that at Ramadan I
think that enjoying Ramadan for the
holiday that it is and celebrating it
with your family is a wonderful thing
regardless of listen Muslims are
imperfect Christians are imperfect
Native Americans are certainly imperfect
that if you go back to old colonial
England Church of England are certainly
imperfect but the Irish are certainly
imperfect but I it's not my business to
tell them what they need to discuss in
st. Patrick's just one I saw that video
and when I talked to Native American
people you know just heard about what
happened I just have empathy for what
they say true and it just makes it
difficult to not speak up for them I
haven't but here's the thing as well but
I also you can also have empathy and
understand that what people are saying
is inaccurate for example I have a
relative who's bipolar okay I'm not
saying any of Americans are bipolar this
is an example I hope you understand this
right I'm a relative who's bipolar and
he will describe situations or scenarios
that are not real and you have empathy
for empathy for him but it's not
necessarily accurate and so I love him
and I care about him and I let him know
that I love them and I care about him
but I I don't engage on the plane on the
wavelength that what you're saying is
accurate a severe mental illness to the
way people feel about my stuff you
listening yes you are depending on what
it is depending on what's defined by the
idea so I use that time you definitely
mentally yeah but again I'm not saying
I'm not conferring bipolar to Native
American I was saying that I can one
connect empathy without necessarily
agreeing with the premise as far as its
accuracy so I can have empathy for
Native Americans saying hey
Thanksgiving to me represents all of
these wars that occurred in these
battles and genocide and I can say hey
you know I understand how you feel but
that's not what Thanksgiving is
celebrating and I can say I understand
how you feel but there also wasn't mass
genocide committed if you actually look
at it by definition it wasn't genocide
there were wars in one side one
one-sided war mind you but you know
there was
that by that definition there's genocide
with the the Mohawks and Mohicans the
Algonquin Xin the Iroquois I mean they
would cannibalize people in front of
their family right if one of them had
advanced technology in other words one
of them were as advanced as the early
settlers this would all be Mohawk
country yeah it wasn't a peaceful
culture everyone has human nature and I
think that taking a holiday and removing
the grace removing the beauty of this
holiday which is meant to symbolize
unity and giving thanks to simply reject
what is human nature acts of evil that
occurred not during this holiday but
somewhere in a timeline I don't think
helps promote healing I think of
anything it's divisive so we can agree
that the idea do we agree that the idea
of Thanksgiving in your head has shifted
into something else not a celebration of
or not an erasure of racism but a
celebration of unity yes what do you
think Thanksgiving is a celebration of
unity can it be a celebration of unity
and like an acknowledgment of the
aeration you can do that yeah that's
time arguing yeah I just think that if
people are going to do that it also
needs to be accurate so the people are
going to teach for example in and I
think we would both agree right on
college campus you guys are certainly
not taught that oh the settlers were
great it was peaceful that's certainly
not what's being taught you know it
could change your mind
so I appreciate himself I thought that
was a good conversation no now before we
continue to remember that these types of
videos can only continue with your
support by joining mug club join up at
louder with credit com / mug club for
tons of more exclusive content including
a Daily Show that you don't get
available on YouTube and to ensure that
videos like this will always continue to
exist on YouTube itself alright let's
get back to it next up Matthew
Matthew nice to meet you Matthew here's
to me I'm Stephen so I can't just
measure the crowd but again just so we
kind of clarify any miscommunications
talking about Thanksgiving today right
and I don't think it's a racist holiday
at all I'm a fan of Thanksgiving I
celebrate it I think it has done me good
and will do me good I say God bless it
happy Thanksgiving to you you are more
than welcome to change my mind you can
have a discussion about this but first
what are you most thankful for um I'd
say most thankful for being here at UT
great school awesome students yeah kokum
notice your family if they're watching
here they're not in a yeah the list name
- okay all right good for you mom so
what what do you disagree with your well
I mean I agree like you were saying that
you think it's the least racist holiday
around there I think there are some
aspects of that that I agree with um
like the idea of you know an Indian
tribe how many other these pilgrims you
know I'll be random American Native
Americans I'm sorry geez
yes I want to go this ban that kind of
dog coming together at a time of need
breaking bread is like that's one of the
most like recognizable American things
in the our past right it's a it's not
racist at all but the idea of what comes
after that I'm sure you heard this
before the mass genocide of these Native
Americans by the very same pilgrims are
like that's an undeniable fact of
American history that we cannot ignore
and to ignore that and pretend that it
did not happen and to not acknowledge it
today what I think would be inherently
racist and that's not to say that I
think we should stop celebrating
Thanksgiving but I think we should
acknowledge that and maybe incorporate
more of a day of mourning into that
celebration as well okay sorry I guess
somebody is booing there see isn't this
this is remarkable you and I can sit
down and disagree and have a discussion
but some people just to choose - boo
yeah good old Austin well listen first
up I want to be really clear mm-hmm I am
NOT denying that there were atrocities
committed on across the board mass
genocide no I'll disagree with that we
can get to that in a second but that
doesn't change what Thanksgiving is
first and so what a lot of people do is
they try and take actions afterward acts
of evil committed afterward to discredit
the idea of Thanksgiving
and you see that that's a national
movement right now you see it was
Columbus Day and indigenous peoples day
if we do that that's what the president
we could do it for any holiday we do for
Christmas we could do it for Veterans
Day we do it for Memorial Day we can do
for Labor Day we could do it for Ramadan
but we choose what we celebrate right
and we choose to celebrate a very
specific instance in 1621 where the
pilgrims peacefully broke bread and
feasted with Native Americans and that
peace lasted for 50 years so um it
sounds more like we're in agreement with
that death Thanksgiving is a good
holiday as we see today I do think it is
a good holiday but I believe there are
some changes that could in may be should
be and you believe those and we'll get
to that in a second but you believe
those changes should be based on the
idea of mass genocide that you said came
from the very same pilgrims well very
unlikely because 310 years but like as
some of those same but like also a lot
of other colonists as well coming from
CONUS so you believe in mass genocide
was committed
I do believe a not entire wiping out of
the Native Americans of course but that
that tribe and a major genocide yes
which trying the Wampanoag tribe
is it one pinaka Wampanoag one another
no you could be writing right now I'm
yeah be terrible I know that we're
taught in school right mass genocide
since like the first grade really right
yeah and it's not true there was no
genocide committed really yeah there
wasn't genocide committed there were
wars fought so um there was actually an
article I think in the University of
Massachusetts that was written they
finally it's the closest estimate that I
found you know the estimate of how many
Native Americans were wiped out it's
about 50% and that's a lot but you know
how many of the settlers were wiped out
about 30 percent yeah so it's not really
indicative of the genocide that's
indicative of wars that were fought and
and one side one and granted it was a
pretty one-sided battle with one side
swinging the hammer and that was the
guys with the white beards and the funny
hats right in front of uniforms but that
being said you know the Native Americans
did try to commit genocide against other
tribes they tried to wipe other tribes
off the face of North America and so I
think that if we're going to single out
colonialists and settlers for what
happened I think when you do it
accurately
wasn't mass genocide there were wars
fought and they were much more effective
we also need to recognize that it was
happening on arguably a much more
barbaric level before the settlers came
here and I don't think that's taught in
school right I would just argue that a
lot of the Native Americans were
defending themselves
like on their land the land that was
theirs first and then the colonists came
and yes they broke the a lot of them
were peaceful and tried to like break
bread as we now know but you know they
were a lot of the a lot of times
initiating the conflict and that's not
all that's not true all the time
I know but yeah and the piece was broken
because they killed an English
translator really right to which quaint
up some miscommunication doesn't you
start a whole war but I'm talk about
Native Americans within Native Americans
mm-hmm this idea that it was a peaceful
horseback culture it's just not true I'm
sure you well actually maybe do you know
that they hadn't domesticated horses I
did not know that they didn't use horses
that's a big reason they got a lot of
the diseases they came in contact with
animals if they'd never domesticated
before you know this idea that we
deliberately transmitted smallpox
blankets centuries before germ theory
and the truth is they had never been in
a horse right and so you develop
immunity so um it wasn't a horse back
culture they didn't use the wheel it
wasn't a peaceful culture they would
cannibalize people sometimes do it
before they killed the rest of the
family so the family could know that
their their patriarch had been
cannibalized you know so when we talk
about this country and sort of I know I
don't think your suggestion if we were
we should give the land back to America
no it's I mean then you couldn't pick
hoodoo yeah that's a whole different
ballgame like you but I'm not denying
the atrocities that were committed right
I just find it unproductive and I think
if this is kind of a through-line
particularly on campus to teach kids
when we talk about Thanksgiving to say
or Columbus Day you have it actually
they were a bunch of mass genocide
acetyls when that's not really the case
there was human nature at play evil on
all sides and the colonialists you know
what became the United States of America
are singularly unique for ending that
barbarism in record time mm-hmm so I
think that's important yeah and I agree
with you I just think that um you know
sovereignty is today it's a totally
different meaning you know it's just a
day to come you know a lot of Native
Americans like they aren't even like
mentioned in the conversate
and sometimes when it comes to
Thanksgiving by a lot of people today
it's just like a day of coming together
with family a day of just breaking bread
and that's great I think that's awesome
I love Thanksgiving I'm just saying that
really that can apply to any holiday
like you said and I I think you said
that I'm yes that's why I say
discrediting a holiday that we choose to
celebrate because of evil to proceed it
could be used with any holiday right and
and I think that we try to do that a lot
with Thanksgiving because it tries to
lay all the guilt at the feet of white
European settlers and I think it's an
inaccurate depiction whereas
Thanksgiving is a very specific instance
that we celebrate because it was a
moment of the old world and new world
breaking bread peacefully and I think
that that's not really talked very much
it gets lost in the shuffle because the
way I look at it is hey we did it once
we did it for 50 years we should be able
to do that again mm-hmm you know
especially consume the negativity out
there yeah yeah and I would have to say
though like and this is this could be
controversial in a lot by itself but
like if I were to make like some sort of
like comparison right it'd be like I've
ever people make the argument that what
if you know the Jewish people of Europe
in you know the 1930s 1940s came
together with like the Nazi Party this
is before like anything happened writing
they they had a great moment of peace
and like broke bread and have a great
conversation a lot of dictators like
where Adolf Hitler came together with
like a lot of Jewish people just like
said like hey like we're bros and
everything and then the Holocaust
happens like a couple months later like
we're still celebrate that day that they
came together and they broke bread if
they made a holiday of that I don't
think it's an apt comparison and the
reason why is because it's not mass
genocide again when you have 30% of the
settlers who were wiped out I mean how
many gestapo how many SS were taking out
my Jews
not 30 but yeah no I thought no they
were taken out by thank God the settlers
the Americans with a new world but I we
came on and Native Americans would have
never been able to do that because I
didn't use the wheel so um I think
little um planes I mean that's an
example - like right now let's say let's
say those early the settlers had never
come right right and by the way the idea
of mass genocide for example I don't
know if you noticed but Manhattan was
purchased the island of Manhattan mm-hmm
so we purchased it for what they call 60
guilders worth which I know sounds like
an RPG game but that was basically a
ship full of like close to 10,000 pelts
and timber and nut wood and it was Alan
Ave and I believe that Canarsie there's
some dispute but they lived in what we
now know is modern Brooklyn okay so they
sold it
it's purchased and the colonists said
okay we want we want to now live in
Manhattan well they didn't keep any
records and they didn't really
understand the concept of personal
property so if they come back and say
well we thought it was at least it's
like well not a second we gave you a
ship full of thousands of pelts and wood
because this is our land now and then
what we're taught in class often is they
kicked people out of Manhattan no what
happened was they believed they were
purchasing Manhattan these tribes didn't
understand personal property the same
way so granted there's a
miscommunication but after that when the
settlers had set up camp with the
families and created the island of
Manhattan they said no you can't come
back here and just take the land back
and then a war starts I don't see that
as genocide that's different from Adolf
Hitler saying we need to rid the country
of Jews that never actually happened
here in the United Sates we never sought
to completely rid the country of Native
America you don't think so no we didn't
that's why you have more people have a
percentage of Native American than ever
before like Johnny Depp is 1/16 Cherokee
er Elizabeth Warren right just one 1024
charity Cherokee
I guess she probably regrets that
23andme now because she just proved that
she's the whitest person in America I
have more sub-saharan Africa to me than
she has Cherokee and her but there was a
lot of intermarrying there was a lot of
intermarriage the idea first was to have
them assimilate to become one culture
and if not then there were Wars that
occurred and by the way the wars weren't
just phosphorus that versus the natives
the war is what we don't have enough
people right the wars were natives
versus the natives who sided with the
guys who had guns and horses
I mean we talked to just recently we
talked to the gentleman who was talking
about Tom South America I think he
brought up Cortes they're only a few
hundred conquistadors and many many many
many many thousands right of Mayans and
Aztecs what happened other tribes were
enslaved and they said I'm gonna take my
chances with the guys with the red
beards and shiny hats because I'm tired
of being cannibalized enslaved and
scalped so this idea that it was mass
genocide that we tried to purge the
country of Native Americans and that it
was a peaceful horseback culture that
lived in harmony before us it couldn't
be further from the truth doesn't mean
that the weren't acts evil committed
from some of the settlers right but I do
think and I would I would ask you this
do you think though because it seems
like some of this information is is new
to you and I will tell you this it was
new to me when I was an adult because I
was raised in Canada I kinda had to
educate myself right but in school they
do disproportionately paint the acts of
evil or way the acts of evil on the
scale that of the colonists and really
acknowledge the barbarism and brutality
and violence from the natives that went
on for far longer and I do think they do
teach us about that aspect later like
maybe like in high scores like a
definitely college right like right acts
of at the acts of brutality that the
Native Americans did like you were
saying the scalping the cannibalism it's
just I think in especially in elementary
school they are trying to tell us you
know that they the colonists came and
just kind of invaded these lands which
isn't true per se right but I do think
they are the ones that initiated the
conflict most of the time and they are
the ones that came to this land to try
to take that land and that's I think
that's a fact
I don't I don't know if there's any
disputes there but like there is a
racist like I still think there is a
racist intention there not necessarily
because of like the color of their skin
in a sense but they did come to like
take these lands and that breaking of
bread on that day was important but I
think we should just also recognize that
and whether that includes like not
getting rid of things saving that's
ridiculous right um but maybe but you
know it's proposed by oh yeah that's
ending like Columbus Day to indigenous
peoples day right what I think maybe
that grants a little bit more mayor but
that's a topic for like
time and I just think somebody
indigenous people say they were just
here for a long time and then someone
discovered it indigenous were celebrated
we're choosing to celebrate a day where
a new world was discovered doesn't mean
that everything was perfect so my point
is once you have a sliding scale of
since everything's not perfect we have
to throw the baby out with the bathwater
and do it with a holiday is is not only
something that I don't agree with but I
think there's a far more sinister
undertone in that there is this
proactive goal that I've seen on campus
and from a lot of professors to paint
Western European colonialists as far
more evil or ill intentions than they
were and to gloss over the good that
they did all right I think they did a
lot more good than the Native Americans
ever did I really do believe that let me
ask you this I noticed your eyes go like
wait what all right that's how that
reaction so before you know Columbus
sailed the ocean blue in 1492 right
first Thanksgiving 1621 okay so let's
just start with Thanksgiving right 1621
because it's kind of first Maine
interactions okay so before 1621 how
long and I know this there were many
Native American tribes and they were
boring when you said it for a long time
but how long were they here before 1621
thousands of years yeah let's agree
let's just put a general thousands of
years we both agree on that right right
okay thousands of years okay they were
still enslaving scalping brutally
beating killing women burning people
alive right they were still doing that
when the colonists got here okay so 1621
from that point how long did it take for
us to actually just outlaw the practice
of slavery from from which point from
1621 roughly 200 years yeah so thousands
of years no progress 200 years
singularly unique and not only ending
scalping and burning alive and
cannibalism which I didn't engage in but
actually ending slavery really still
goes on across the world right still
goes on not only in the Middle East but
it also goes on and a lot of tribes that
are mostly untouched by the new world
mm-hmm so I would say that is a for
going to teach it we need to teach that
there was a war one side for me sure
that came in the conquered this land you
can say that they stole it you can even
ignore all the property rights and the
trees that were signed and just say they
stole the land that being said they did
far more profit as far as progressing
toward human
for everybody then the Native Americans
ever had and that's an irony that I
think is lost in a lot of progressive
student that is fear so I guess like my
question to you would be Saudi would you
be in favor of creating a day of
mourning or would you just say like they
don't deserve it at this point I think
that every every single history class
that's taught on campus is effectively a
class of mourning it's a curriculum of
mourning I think that if right now if I
were to go and you can disagree with me
and tell me thing I'm wrong but I think
if I were to go into any history class
that teaches about the early settlers
here on UT campus I would wager that 80%
of them would teach the story of the
colonialists as evil as conniving as
trickery and that they committed mass
genocide I think that's why you came in
and used the word mass genocide I think
you're somewhat parroting from what
you've learned from your professors and
so I don't think I would agree with you
that that is that is the term they do
use mass genocide right and I said like
I do not think it was a mass genocide I
do think there are aspects of it they
were though but I do see your point I
think massive numbers of people died
right right but sometimes it went both
ways for example when when Colonia was
four caught by surprise you know when
you talk about Wounded Knee they don't
tell you that only 38 your European
settlers were killed because the number
was disproportionate one side had guns
and horses mm-hmm what's gonna happen if
there's a gang more here at UT and one
side has cars and ar-15s and the other
side has bow and arrows and have to get
on your bird scooters maybe it's not
mass genocide it's not like that's
happening in Hong Kong right now
protesters pretty much yeah not exactly
the thing because it's not really nice
genocide but right it's true that the
people are being oppressed by and using
get really close in Arizona if you well
I you know have those been confirmed I
think so I think I can see footage
eivin's I haven't seen that footage
interest I do know it is a disproportion
just reporting level of power from the
government these protesters all right
well that's a whole different discussion
if we can get into my thoughts and
prayers are with those people in Hong
Kong
unlike the NBA apparently they got to
keep keep those dollars coming in from
China but my point is there's plenty of
morning because that's what's taught to
young people I think that is what's
primarily taught and I think the way
that the scales have gone too far the
other way or when we want to celebrate
Thanksgiving there are four more people
saying well actually that's problematic
then there are saying hey let's take a
moment
Thanks I don't really think we need to
put any more on that side of the scale
what I'm doing here is trying to retype
the scale to say no no no the United
States is a great country I'm really
glad that the United States exists I'm
really glad that they did discover the
new world and I'm going to give thanks
on this day regardless of what my
professor tells me right so hopefully
well I hope that was productive yeah I
really appreciate I appreciate your
candor to entice me it helps me to learn
- what you guys are talking about in
classrooms and stuff because I suspect
as much because of when I went to
college but yeah it's it's a one-sided
it just helps out have a conversation
without protesting yes well there was
someone who started there and I think
yeah unfortunate I think she she shut
him out but I will just have to say Jeff
Epstein didn't kill himself
[Applause]
if I tell my mom and she tells you I'm
on it
if I tell my mom
Meredith steven crowder nice to meet you
nice to meet you I don't know how
familiar you are with what we do with
these change my mind segments but the
ideas that we sit down and rationalize
our positions on controversial topics
it's not meant to be a debate today I
know this is a sensitive topic for a lot
of people Thanksgiving particularly
there's a way that the way it's taught
on campus I do not believe that
Thanksgiving is a racist holiday I think
it's probably the most inclusive
national holiday that we celebrate I
think it has done me good will do me
good I say God bless it and if you
disagree you're more than welcome to
change my mind Happy Thanksgiving to you
what are you most thankful for right now
I'm most thankful for my family that's a
nice one you have a good family yeah my
mom and dad I wouldn't be Who I am
without them that's very nice a lot of
people were thankful to be going to UT
but you're the first one to say they
were thankful for your family I wouldn't
be going to UT without my family
they're the rid of everything I do
wonderful so um you're more than welcome
to take this opportunity to change my
mind okay here's what I think I think
that when you get down to the semantics
of the platform you know Thanksgiving
isn't racist changed my mind
I think like from the jump the lines get
blurred okay because the denotation of
the word racist is to have prejudiced or
discriminatory attitudes towards other
races okay and so I think that when we
look at the semantics and the denotation
but know Thanksgiving is not racist I
agree with you however I do think that
its history is a moveable rooted and
some colonialist
and oppressive events I think that
that's an arguable I mean I think that
Thanksgiving yeah Thanksgiving I mean
yes Thanksgiving specifically I think
the you know and of course the history
is pretty blurry and every single
textbook seems to teach a little
differently but white settlers came over
here and they displaced parts of
Nativity one second do you say every
textbook will teach it differently I
mean a lot of textbooks probably
shouldn't because very clearly there's a
problem
1621 the pilgrims of the Wampanoags
and want to pull eggs well I always get
the pronunciation wrong after those
raising cannabis Iroquois the Algonquin
I'm not as familiar with the American
truck but no it's very specific 1621
when they had a feast for 50 years
whenever you frame like like you said
this is a very sensitive issue for some
people and I think on some level is an
important issue not a lot of it doesn't
cross everybody's minds honestly I never
stop to think it's Thanksgiving racist
verbatim like that and until I saw your
poster walking to my table over there
okay my issue is that whenever you frame
something like this as Thanksgiving is
racist you oversimplify it I think it's
not racist yeah you're saying it's not
racist it's response to people saying
it's a racist holiday including some
professors here it's not racist however
I do think that do you acknowledge that
some of the history behind the
Thanksgiving holiday is rooted in
oppressive or colonialist histories not
Thanksgiving though so that's why I
think it's important when you say
different textbooks teach different
versions what is what is your
understanding of why we celebrate
Thanksgiving my understanding of why we
celebrate Thanksgiving is that okay
technically that first Thanksgiving is
argued to have been the pilgrims they
were here they had a successful harvest
and they invited some of the native
tribes to come with them to celebrate
their good harvests okay that's my
understanding of it however Thanksgiving
wasn't technically made a national
holiday in the United States until 1863
Lincoln 150 years later sure so it's
very blurry when the first Thanksgiving
was especially considering the native
tribes both in Europe and here in the
United States had a feast to celebrate
harvest for hundreds of years it's it's
it's not it's not it's not blurry okay
but it's not blurry historically we
actually have and this is something that
you'll read a lot online we actually
have multiple corroborating historical
documents regarding the feast of 1621
including the names of attendees and the
reason that then you know then yeah
George Washington who wanted to make it
a holiday in October Jefferson didn't
recognize it the reason Abraham Lincoln
recognizes he said in 1863 an official
holiday was after the Emancipation
Proclamation after some big battles in
the Civil War
said we need a national holiday to unify
the country right now there to be some
healing what example could we point to
in here
three very specifically a very specific
example where this has happened oh let's
go to that perfect example of
convergence of the old world in the new
world in 1621 with those early settlers
in the Wampanoag sir I might get that
wrong tribes with peace that lasted for
50 years for 50 years so the reason it's
a celebration the reason it was reckoned
by the way the message wasn't it wasn't
an actual country so you have a lot of
holidays that weren't federally
recognized until later but it was
federally recognized later for that
specific date in 1621 there is no
dispute about that now if you have a
problem with other examples of colonial
settling and I think these are
legitimate grievances fine but as far as
Thanksgiving the holiday and why we
celebrate it no I don't think there's
any any deeply rooted racially motivated
history or negativity I don't I still
think that the framing of the issue is
poor on your part and I think that stems
back to a lot of what you do here and
you conversing with all of these college
students who ultimately on average
aren't as well-informed as you are
sometimes I like I as a college student
you know I had to do a whole lot of
googling before I come over here to talk
to you betting the sources from which I
was reading from on Google I just but
sure you all know that year if you're
going to one of the best universities in
the country you know we should but we
don't and I think it's super easy for
you to capitalize on that because you
know more than we do and your point and
straight up Thanksgiving is not racist
and it's really easy for you to make
that point and the first thing I said is
we don't have any professors are willing
to debate do you know professors here to
be willing to we would be more than
happy I don't know I doubt that's so you
want to so you acknowledge that the
challenge as well something that the
professor's will engage in discussion
and they're not teaching you this the
fact that you have to this is basic
information that everyone should know
about American history Thanksgiving
that's not really a gotcha that's
actually a disservice from your college
professors and your high school teachers
to have not taught you the actual
history of Thanksgiving
but we not agree on that I suppose we
could yes okay because my goal is not to
be rude or to upset you
and I would like to hear the point of
view is but no I would disagree with you
you can still agree with you that there
is anything as far as racially support
you know supremacist or as far as
violent colonialism with Thanksgiving
the holiday why we celebrated I don't
deny that there were acts and evil
committed on all sides afterwards but no
Thanksgiving I have no problem okay and
I want to think that it's fair but I
will all circulate that I still think
there's a lot of accountability and
acknowledgement and I say accountability
but that's only because I can't think of
a better word at the end of the day the
pilgrims were acknowledged is the first
successful settlers like because you
know there were a couple examples here
and there of people coming here and
trying to establish something but the
pilgrims are the most famous successful
example of Europeans level of settlers
coming to the eastern seaboard of the
continental United States and like I
said being successful in establishing
community and I think that that was the
first domino okay I really do believe
that was the first domino Thanksgiving
was a domino not necessarily
Thanksgiving was a domino but the
pilgrims coming here was a domino if you
read about the history and all of the
subsequent years after Thanksgiving
eight of people's were killed by plagues
and eventually displaced by the spread
of colonies they're actually killed by
plagues even before Thanksgiving because
some of the French settlers left and
since they hadn't domesticated animals
they would come in contact with diseases
like the idea that smallpox blankets us
I mean that's a myth we didn't
understand have germ theory but they did
come into contact for example horses to
do that they hadn't domesticated horses
I didn't know that actually horses yeah
one basic ated yeah and so they so
actually I think we came to an abandoned
village at the time of Thanksgiving
because they'd already been wiped out
due to some diseases but I would like to
hear about the dominoes so thanks the 50
years after Thanksgiving because that's
when warring started the dominoes and
what you'd expect I think it's a domino
effect and I think that even if we
acknowledge Thanksgiving isn't racist
and that the people who first celebrated
people who celebrated the first
Thanksgiving as we call it you know the
first established ritualistic feast to
thank God or the gods whatever they
believed for their good harvest I think
that those people were the first truly
successful settlers and that they
established a trend and that from that
point forward subjugation and
colonialism rooted and bigoted ideas and
oppression I think that's where it
started colonialism you know let's have
that discussion because I'm trying to
focus on Thanksgiving but I think that
you've actually been very reasonable and
we both agreed that Thanksgiving itself
is not a problem but it seems like you
have a problem with the settlers
afterward and colonialism because I
might disagree with you on that so let's
do that let's try don't think
Thanksgiving know Thanksgiving is not a
problem what is a problem however is if
we try to argue that we shouldn't
acknowledge that there is bad history
around the first things giving later
afterward yeah over 50 years later and I
don't know but then I think we might
disagree as to what history is bad or
what the motivations were so I actually
think I'm still very grateful that they
did settle here and that the United
States was colonized so that we can sit
here and have open free and open
discussions so I would love to hear your
opinion on sort of colonization and what
maybe would have been the right thing to
do as opposed to what happened I don't
think there was a right way to do it mmm
I honestly don't and I think that the
way people thought back then wasn't
suited to the right sorry the right way
to have done things I wish that I could
say oh well they could have done it this
way unless people could have died unless
conflicts could have happened and less
native peoples could have been oppressed
or subjugated or displaced I wish that I
could have some hypothesis however I
don't think I have to have a hypothesis
for a better way to say that the way it
was done wasn't good enough or wasn't
right I do agree that there were
certainly some acts of evil committed on
both sides and in celebrating
Thanksgiving that's
the lack of recognizing that there were
some acts of evil committed on both
sides for example Native Americans have
their own holidays if they celebrate and
they were far more barbaric and brutal
toward each other than even the the
colonizers were I mean you can go back
to the Mohican versus the Milwaukee
Algonquin zone the Iroquois you go down
south and you know you talk about the
conquistadors how do you think that
Cortes came with five hundred
conquistadors in Concord tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people other members of tribes were
being enslaved and forced to carry gold
as well as being disemboweled and
cannibalized and they said hey we're
going to go with the guys and the funny
shiny hats so I think it's important
than if we do that I agree with you I
think then we need to recognize the evil
which is a part of the human condition
that was committed from all different
groups as opposed to singularly Western
culture Western Europeans the Americans
our colonizers the Native Americans
engaged in acts of evil the colonizers
did at some point they did try to trade
by the way and purchase land and there
were some misunderstandings because they
didn't the same concept of personal
property rights you could certainly
argue that in Africa they should
celebrate no holidays because the
African slave trade and the whole Middle
Eastern and Arabic world they still have
slavery my point is that doesn't
discredit the positive that we find in a
holiday and I think that history as
being taught here on this campus from
what I've encountered teaches that
Western Europeans who came here the
colonizers are singularly unique for
acts of evil that were committed across
the spectrum when the reality is we were
singularly unique in ending evil in
record time that's just an opinion
of course I think these are all opinions
we've shared here not as the history of
Thanksgiving but yes opinions on whether
we think it's a good thing or a bad
manager I don't think that we should
just cry out the goods of the
Thanksgiving holiday I don't think it's
racist I don't think that it is
inherently a bad thing I simply think
that if we're going to have this
discourse the first thing we need to do
is acknowledge like you said that it's
not all good and it's not all bad I
think that most people don't have that
general sense of awareness that it
wasn't all good and it wasn't all bad
I'm
was a sense awareness in this campus
that it was all bad I mean the pilgrims
pilgrims didn't pull up and slaughter
everybody and the natives weren't
complete savages but then it also wasn't
just everybody sitting there singing
Kumbaya on the Thanksgiving table of
course not
all of these are an accurate
representation was it Thanksgiving
that's what's so unique about it it was
very peaceful that's why I love
Thanksgiving it shows that it can be
done but isn't that a good thing to to
highlight a moment in time of humanity
where people came together regardless of
cultural differences I mean didn't speak
the same language old world new world
and for 50 years lived in peace and
celebrated and traded together
isn't that something there's so much
negativity out there right now isn't
that a good thing to find a silver
lining and say hey we did it once it can
be done again that's why I love
Thanksgiving and that's why the reason I
say it's not racist is because it is
being accused of being racist all across
campuses in the country and some people
want to remove it from the national
registry of nationally recognized
holidays I think it's a beautiful thing
I think it's a wonderful thing you know
I need to go so before I do that I'd
like to live back to my point that on a
linguistic and semantic level saying
that Thanksgiving is racist makes
absolutely zero sense and it's fair for
you to argue that Thanksgiving isn't
racist but what people are going to come
here people are arguing about something
different than what this sign says when
they come and sit down here to talk to
you
and I think it's really important that
you know that but I think you already
know that I don't know what that means
are you attributing motive I am
attribute motive okay what motive are
you attributing I mean eyes like I said
I think you know that what college kids
like me are gonna come sit down and
argue to you and what you're going to
argue to us isn't the same thing I think
that we're arguing two different points
I think we are arguing the same point I
don't think we're arguing the same
points whatsoever and I don't think
anybody else who comes to sit down and
talk to you today is going to be arguing
the same point and what do you think
they'll be arguing
I mean I think they wouldn't be looking
at it from different sects if like I
said or not like I said like I thought
and if you had to say my apologies it's
okay most people aren't gonna look at it
from a semantic and linguist linguistic
perspective most people aren't going to
sit down and think history I think
that's why it was very clear and saying
there were active evil committed all
across the board but Thanksgiving itself
most people aren't going to think what
does the word racist actually mean and
does it make sense for them to pose this
question this way and so most people are
going to come and talk about the evils
of colonialism and how the clump and how
the colonizers were racists and are
going to be arguing about something
completely and totally different than
what you were going to be arguing no
we've already discussed that with
several people we did that here right
now I know I didn't cut you off you
aren't you major points and I think that
we both have had a productive discussion
and I was open to talking about
colonialism exclusively outside of
Thanksgiving - I just think that the
issue has been poorly framed and that if
you want to incite an intelligent
discourse about such a prevalent issue
then you should frame it differently how
would you frame it because right now you
they want to remove it from the
nationally recognized holidays because
of it being racist I disagree
so I'm sitting emphatically
declaratively I don't think it's racist
I think it's a wonderful holiday
how would you frame it I wouldn't just
say Thanksgiving isn't racist change my
mind I would say here are the positives
of Thanksgiving I acknowledge XYZ
negatives but I still don't think it's
racist
and we have that I said that in this
very discussion somebody has to come in
on a sign it's tough to fit on this we
talked about it we did talk about it but
most people aren't gonna come and sit
down and talk to you those people out
there can barely even hear us that's
there and most of these kids are super
catchy love's liberal and aren't gonna
go watch your YouTube channel to hear
what you actually have to say then it's
kind of sad that most people don't
contribute their time to hearing both
sides point of view but that's just the
reality of it and that's why I have to
do the job but professors don't do its
bate and thumbnails and I disagree with
you I don't I don't think that an hour
and a half unedited video uploaded as
quick bake but I appreciate you taking
the time
[Music]
be sure to tune in next Monday for a
special bonus edition I've changed my
mind
if you enjoy this installment have
changed my mind click one of these other
installments in the videos playing in
boxes here that's the only way you'll
find them because if you search change
my mind they might not show up because
YouTube's deemed them controversial
subscribe hit the notification bell and
you know we'll we'll see you but we
probably won't